all right joining us now with much more
author of the best seller never give an
inch he's the former Secretary of State
former CIA director former Congressman
friend of the program Mike Pompeo by the
way Mr secretary welcome glad to have
you
good to be with you I had you on my
radio show
your book is phenomenal you tell the the
back story of meetings with Putin and
she and Little Rocket Man and Elton John
that story behind that uh this is too
serious though tonight I want you to
First
analyze examine give your thoughts on
how nonchalant Biden and his
administration is about this and what
would be happening if you and Donald
Trump were back in charge and this was
going on
Sean thanks for having me on I can I can
nearly guarantee you that that balloon
would still not be flying if we were
still there this is this is embarrassing
more important than that it is dangerous
I don't know what they're collecting it
is it is certainly not a surveillance
tool or weather tool if it's a weather
tool we should go grab it make sure and
offer to give it back to them so they
can know what the weather's going to be
like the truth is the truth is we we
need to figure out what's in there we
should then share that with the American
people the most transparent
Administration history should be
transparent we should be very worried
too there could be Western technology on
that balloon we should find out who made
all the equipment that's inside of that
as well and share that so that the
American people can get a full picture
I'll give you a counter example when the
Chinese Communist party was spying from
its Consulate in Houston Texas they were
running the biggest spying operation in
the history of the United States of
America we shut it down we closed it out
we kicked the spies out and we protected
the American people what you're seeing
today with this balloon flying over the
United States is real weakness and
whether they're actually collecting
important information or not I promise
you Xi Jinping is testing America he's
testing President Biden and we are
failing that test he will view this as a
green light for further aggression why
is our Pentagon telling the American
people that we assess that the balloon
does not present a military or physical
threat to the people on the ground at
this time
and they didn't tell us for days Mr
secretary don't the people in this
country have a right to know that the
Communist Chinese have sent a balloon
the size of three buses flying over our
country
we absolutely do President Biden should
address the American people from the
Oval Office or somewhere and explain to
us why they've made the decisions they
have I don't know why the Pentagon has
such confidence maybe maybe they've been
able to shut it off I I truly don't know
but they need to explain to us what's
going on why they've permitted to
continue to fly even if even if there's
nothing going on inside that balloon
it's in American airspace it's a Chinese
balloon they're violating the most
fundamental sovereignty of the United
States we've seen that by Administration
they won't protect our Southern border
now they won't protect our skies either
this is this is truly dangerous stuff
because every bad guy XI xingping
chairman Kim all the bad guys in the
world saw they saw 13 Americans killed
in Afghanistan we've now seen an
invasion of Europe and we now have
Chinese flying balloons over our country
you know our secretary of state blinken
said China's decision to fly this uh
reconnaissance balloon over the
continental U.S is unacceptable and
irresponsible okay that's stating the
obvious and he canceled trip that he had
planned for China next week
and maybe with you could tell us without
giving away military or intelligence
secrets in any way
I want to know would we have the ability
to get to that
balloon reconnaissance balloon and
actually recover it and take it down and
actually find out what is in it would
that be a possibility because we can't
do that we really have from my point of
view one action and that is to blow it
into Smithereens those are the only two
options I see would the first option be
possible in your view
yeah Sean I think I think it's possible
to achieve I don't know exactly what's
driving this balloon I don't know the
mechanics behind it we have no nobody's
told us but it wouldn't surprise me if
we have the ability to make sure that
that comes down in a way that we can
both keep the American people safe
that's important too but they had a shot
when it was over very very sparsely
populated land they've just made a
different choice
uh Sean they've made a choice to say no
keep flying fly it on out nothing to see
here folks it's these are scary times
there's no doubt about it uh
congratulations on your best seller uh
secretary Pompeo never give an inch we
appreciate you being here thank you sir
John thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else